the main a2 road into dover the queue
was continuous
the uk government estimated some 1500
lorries had been stranded
but a drive around the approach roads to
the port revealed many many more than
that
parked up and waiting for news news
eventually came
that the blockade would be lifted but
only for those with proof of a negative
covid test
and that is no use at all to the
thousands of drivers
whose hopes of reaching home for
christmas are now gone
now it's done it's finished
from here to go home we have about
almost 2 000 miles it's about
45 hours to drive no stop
no sleep just drive
and we can make it if covet testing is
to be the precondition for reopening the
border with france that presents an
enormous logistical challenge for the uk
authorities
there are now thousands of truck and van
drivers parked up in lay bys
all across the county of kent and
getting the testing to them
or them to the testing is going to be an
enormous task
and all this just days before christmas
this german businessman was just minutes
away from boarding his ferry
when the blockade came into force yes
three cars from freedom so if i'd been
10 minutes earlier i would be now on the
other side
and be safe and at home for christmas
with my family
he's resigned to the possibility that
he'll spend christmas stuck in dover
but he says the uk authorities have been
totally inadequate
down there there are public toilets
which are not open for the drivers
they should be open i think they should
be handled coffee or tea to the drivers
immediately
government should do something and they
should do it immediately
the airfield at manston in kent has been
made a temporary lorry park but the
hundreds of vehicles here are again
just a section of the true scale of the
problem and the scarcity of food and
sanitary facilities
is also creating tensions the member for
parliament for dover
blames france for this crisis i just
think the way in which the french
government reacted
was just really unhelpful i mean the uk
and the french government the haulage
industry the ferry industry
they've worked hand in glove over the
last few months since trans
since the virus started to make sure
that it's managed and i think that's
what should have happened here
as night fell in dover the rain arrived
and the drivers staged a blockade of
their own
[Applause]
[Music]
many of these truckers and van drivers
now facing their third night stranded
here at dover tempers are clearly
starting to fray
they've occupied the roundabout which is
here at the entrance
to the port behind me they've blocked
the traffic there is a long snaking line
of lorries in that direction
the police are trying to restore order
but for the moment
they're not being successful i stayed in
the parking on two days
my my children my son my
daughter is crying for me
reinforcements restored order but the
situation
remains tense paul brennan al jazeera
dover